I mean they also make the most decadent
large cars too they can do everything
yeah I just like their fashion because
it's so loud
that's true though that's a good way to
explain it yeah I heard they all live in
apartments but have the best clothes
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so uh in Italy there has been
a Court ruling that found a School
Janitor not guilty of groping a student
because the ACT only lasted less than 10
seconds which has now sparked outrage
doesn't that sound familiar like
remember that one kid who like that
teenage dude that was like or maybe
wasn't a team but he was in college and
he was like accused of being this girl
behind a dumpster and then the defense
was like oh it was only like 10 minutes
of pleasure he shouldn't be prosecuted
like that was their defense what the
[__] and that worked right it kind of
did yeah which sad to say he's not even
in jail so the context of this one in
her testimony the then 17 year old girl
said that the act happened back in April
of 2022 she was climbing the staircase
at the school with a friend she
testified that she pulled up her
trousers and then felt a hand tucked
inside them under her briefs touching
her buttocks what the [__] uh the in in
Italian I'm sure the janitor said love
you know I was joking okay according to
the teenagers testimony oh that wasn't
just joking wait but he's a he's a grown
ass man you said he's Italian this was
in Italy well I thought you said India
yeah Italy one of the clients of the gym
we were talking about the Maharaja Mac
one of the clients at the gym she's a
very Italian she's like she lives there
and [__] you know but she lives out here
for work she makes pasta from scratch
kinda like she's she's like and I always
hit her with all the stereotypes and
she's like yup very true very true shut
up no no she was telling that she was
like Italian dudes are like a different
breed they're horny yeah like they're
super horny oh the aggressive yeah like
they're hella aggressive and they're
kind of like yo they're Broach yeah I
just told okay in Italy yeah just like
apparently that's just the culture like
a Mexican construction worker oh
probably worse oh that's that's what
that's what I said I said like a Mexican
construction worker and she said
probably worse
I don't know any Italians that aren't
American Italian yeah I I want to go to
Italy bro she drives a Fiat bro that's
very Italian she's devoted I was like
why'd you pick the Fiat she goes it's
Italian and then I go okay so does she
talk like this does she drink coffee for
breakfast
did the Judgment say that the hey it's
okay because it was only 10 so the
judges accepted the defense's argument
that the Act was meant to be a clumsy
joke without you know that type in
seconds is long wait so if you combust
the nut and then turn up 10 seconds you
could technically
r-a-p-e someone and be like that was
just a joke yeah stand up
well this is you know I love this
because this is actually what's going
viral in on Tick Tock and Instagram in
Italy right now oh you gotta hold it
yeah dude that's a lot of affection dude
three seconds in I'm like this is too
rope around a little bit you still got
half the yeah that's a long that's a
long that's a long one well that's a
long one that's the that's the viral
content right now one second is already
too long yeah they're like filming
themselves like groping themselves for
tenses with a timer to show like this is
a [__] long time like this is an app
that can like really jar somebody's
experience or change because even one
second one second in an inappropriate
place is no bueno dude you can't even
hear you can't even insinuate that
you're gonna do it yeah you can't even
go here we come you can't even do that
only with like if they're really cool
yeah yeah but then what about an adult
touching a minor yeah bro even for a
second yeah foxy on the wrong thing
he's like oh he's wearing sketches it's
perfectly fine
oh because the judges they would have to
be guilty right they're like less than
10 seconds yeah he said okay this would
be my audio I think there's something to
also the way and again I'm not trying to
put a blanket statement on Italians or
anything but you're bringing up that
that story with your Italian home girl
that's at the gym where it's like if
culturally everyone's horny these guys
are already like that then it's like the
same thing in like the judges seat it's
kind of like oh it's part of the culture
yeah you know what I mean maybe we're
all horny don't they thinking about it
like in their kids point of view like
man if someone touched my kid I'm gonna
[__] break their hands I don't think
they're thinking that way they probably
do it to their kids it's only 10 taken
another 10 seconds it's okay it's not
this it's not the best when I was
talking to our homie we're just Italian
are you touching me I touch you oh okay
very much when we were talking to our
Italian uh homie she was and I was
telling her I was like yeah me and my
wife are gonna try to go to we want to
go Italy and she goes be careful they're
gonna try to [__] your wife
that's the first thing she said to me
and that's why we started laughing and
we were like oh my I was like I was like
so you're telling me all these dudes are
trying to [__] my wife and they go yeah
if they see that you have a ring they
might be more respectful but if you're
walking around with your girlfriend
they're still they're gonna spit game
yeah right until they see your ears and
then I'll [__] them did you say that I
just be like I hope they're ready
because I love Italian men I love
Italian men I don't get all those vibes
at all really yeah we were in Venice and
then Rome and Florence maybe because
they're looking at Geo and they're like
she's gonna whip my ass oh yeah that's
true yeah Italian guys are short are
they short that's what I heard that's
why they made Fiat look how short that
thing is
if you ride a Ducati if you ride a
Ducati which is Italian this is a
shorter bike too that's why Asians
always like Ducatis because it fits
better well also their cars are also
really small because they got limited
parking space now
I mean they also make the most decadent
large cars too they can do everything
yeah yeah I just like their fashion
because it's so loud
decadent that's true though that's a
good way to explain it yeah I heard they
all live in shitty Apartments but have
the best clothes
you know I didn't get
an Italy I didn't I didn't get the vibe
that that everybody wanted to have sex
with you I had more uh like Hustlers on
tourism you know like oh they'll take a
picture like those like those like shady
dudes they're probably not Italian
though they're like gypsies yeah yeah
more than the let me check out your girl
and grow up your girl I think I think
that's the thing it's like depending on
who you run into like because when we
were there we had in our tour group we
had a lot of women and all the Italian
people were just nice to them but they
weren't like aggressively trying to hook
up with them maybe they were just that
smooth every single time you turn your
head it's like if anything American
people on our two group were doing that
to the girls there like it was more like
that direction but I think it also gets
misrepresented a lot where like like
there was like videos of like these uh
Arab guys in in London that were like
hitting on this uh Thai girl and then
the result of that was like yeah British
people are [__] up they're so racist
but it's like dude those guys are
[__] immigrants to Britain like you
can't put the blanket on the country
they're in yeah you know but if you run
into like just certain types in certain
countries you know it's like if you ran
into me here and I pissed you off you're
not gonna get mad at America because
you're gonna hate Filipino oh you look
you look super American right now like
look at you dude yeah yeah you look like
Marty McFly that's true and Indian guys
what about
compared to friend is just
witnessing American Italians from Boston
hitting on girls all day she goes these
[__] Italians yeah but I'll say this
she lives in Italy
like she lives in it so maybe it's not
the tourist spots maybe the tourist
spots are more like the local spots yeah
the local spots that probably is what it
is yeah or you just have to be a local
because if you're a tourist it probably
won't even bother yeah but because
you're Italian and it's a culture thing
that's why they go 10 seconds
I think if the judge is [__] winking
to the dude then yeah that's it yeah
it's crazy to think that some a lawyer
in the future can cite this case and go
like your honor I'm pleading the 10
second rule but the 10 second the guy
who created the 10 second rule in his
mind he's like I [__] did it again I
nailed it I figured it out you created
the five second rule for food too who's
that guy maybe it only works Italian to
Italian yeah yeah you can't do a you
can't be a tourist probably not I can't
be a tourist and does the timer stop
when he lives can I go like this oh it's
one oh that's one all I can reset no it
has to be all in one it has to be all
what one so that can technically go like
this no no no no no no and this is all
one second I don't know try it see how
it is no you got to walk away for at
least one second too yeah try it for
real try it for real on Nick and let's
see what the limit is here in America
let us know when you get uncomfortable
snow when he gets uncomfortable it's
already getting on
I don't know what time it was when this
guy was holding my arms and you were
holding my arm and you guys were trying
to touch my people try it try it no I
don't like this you like that the guy
walking on it I like the walking get out
of here I got distracted with the walk
talking about I'm not gonna allow it
dude 10 seconds is [__] that's a long
[__] time even once even just
deciding time is crazy yeah
as a reason to Quantum molestation yeah
bro like you're free to go because it
was under 10 seconds that's a crazy rule
that's crazy it's like what he just
kissed you for a second and it's a
janitor so like there's no conduct there
what's Wild to me it's it's longer than
the three second rule of when you have
food on the ground yeah I thought that
was a five second rule depending on what
country you're in I thought it depends
on the condition of the floor yeah
that's also true or the the hunger you
feel like yeah I wonder what other rules
like can you stick your head in a girl's
locker room for 10 seconds like
everything is time based oh man I just
bought it for two minutes the challenge
is like this there's really good
question that's being developed here
this is crazy they gotta like reverse
that is there like in in Italy is there
like a higher Court you can like appeal
that like a supreme court like the
Vatican I feel like yeah we all know how
that goes over there they're like 10
second rule we don't have that we're
gonna extend it to 50 seconds that's too
short no but that only that only works
on same sex because if it's the Vatican
so if it's straight then it's uh
discussed it's wrong it's a sin yeah it
needs to be a little they're like you
touch the girl
punish the girl you're going to hell
[Music]